why should computers learn to see
because old friends can now connect in
real time because no one should have to
go hungry because we believe in second
chances from agriculture to cancer
detection computer vision is not only
teaching computers what to see but how
to respond to our visual world at
Udacity we've built the computer vision
nano degree program for students to
learn about image processing techniques
and methods for object recognition and
tracking so that you can make a deep
impact in any field so why should we
teach computers to see cuz the
possibilities of what we can build
together are limitless